okay okay I would like to thank for the
possibility to talk to you uh this
afternoon or this morning or wherever
you are in the world I'm P carinii from
the ran Center for life science
Technologies and as the name of the new
Institute says we are developing
Technologies for life
science so uh in particular we have been
uh focusing on uh transcript analysis
Technologies and even more in particular
to analyze the fiand of rnas the
previous technology where uh the cap
trap and full length C Technologies and
then we have more recently developed and
redeveloped various version of the cage
technology we this we have been
exploring uh Ares transom and
particularly have Insight on the on the
work of NOA noncoding Aras and I'm going
to touch the various aspect here in this
introductory slide in the next several
minutes so uh just to mention just to
mention the key technology that we are
using now cage so this slide is very is
very crowded but the key Point here is
that we are focusing on capturing the
fand of RNA by making C A only the C
that reach the cap site are selected and
then there are various options we can
sequence the product as it is with the
Illumina or helicos sequencing
instrument and in the past we've been
also using a pro based on uh PCR and and
illum we also been uh working a lot to
automate and to uh have a kit in order
to U uh everybody in the world can uh
reproduce our data so uh cage and CD
technology have been contributed to
various project in the past and we've
been annotating the mouse and Human
Genome in in previous projects in about
a decade ago we have been contributing
uh part particular with cage to the en
code project mod en code project and
also other project going to touch later
in this in this
presentation so to mention um a little
bit more in details our key project this
is the Phantom project uh is one of the
oldest Consortium uh to annotate the
mamalian uh the mamalian genus
particular we start with the mouse we
start with a large collection of cdnas
that help
also to to understand where the genes
are also in the human
genome and we produce more
cdnas and start to standardize rules for
the notation and in 2005 using cdns
Technologies and cage we figure out that
the most of the genome is
transcribed and there are many
non-coding rnas we continue using cage
to prove that just using sequencing of
RNA we can Fair regulatory networks this
was published in 2009 natur genetics and
now to uh conclude this overview of the
Phantom is is is is the paper that came
out is the series of paper came out in
March including two nature papers
showing providing a very extensive map
of transcription in in in human and
mouse primary cells I'm going to expand
the various aspect of this just to um
summarize quickly the finding that um
the uh landscape what we understand
about the landscape of the transcript
must been changing because uh a decade
ago we expected something like many
protein coding rnas however we found out
that there is a the large majority is
represented by non-coding rnas they are
not translated they constitute more than
half of the
transcript and uh also more more
importantly many groups recently that
are um doing quite a lot of experiment
to prove that they have a function and
they very often regulate that the
transum or the the the Gen transom or
instability interactive protein have
quite a lot of multitude fraction that
unfortunately we don't have the time to
explore in details here today except for
some of the
examples now we have a this technology
um to profile um with very high
throughput the fper m so what we can ask
immediately is what is the complexity of
initiation s in in the Balian genome and
in the preliminary study we have been
exploring the difference in brain
regions of mouth and in in in in first
set of libraries we explore was the we
checked the initiation of of
transcription in various tissue like
hippocampus somato sensory cortex visual
cortex and cellum and for this Gene here
we see that there are preferentially
expressed promoter that are very
specific for each of of the tissues so
this is very important because if you
ask what is the promoter of the
hippocampus or what is promoter of the
somato sensory cortex or the visual
cortex they are probably different and
if you look at the regulation of
transcription is very likely that the
transcription factor that bind in one
region or the other region are probably
uh different and tissue specific so this
is very important to
to um um profile expression that is
specific for uh for um each
tissue now
um uh what we can uh say about the how
many transcriptions start decide how
many promoters are in the mouse or in
the human genome and we've been
addressing this in the Phantom 5 in the
Phantom 5 we have been uh analyzing uh
something like a 3,000 samples
importantly the collection of samples is
very important so most of them are are
from primary cells in biological
replicas about half of the sample here
on the on the left are snapshot so many
different cells and duplicate and this
is published and the unpublished part is
here on on the time Co where we have
been taking 32 of those cells have been
differentiating or under various stimuli
and we are analyzing now uh the Dynamics
of of this stimulation and and we we
don't have a paper yet on this
one so by analyzing this very large
resource we can now um uh uh say
something about the extent of the of the
initiation
site and uh uh also we can have a very
broad catalog of expression in in in 900
under 47 samples and and this is just
the the top of the of the list of of of
another 47 samples in human and this
first Gene is the G fibril aity protein
so very specific for the brain so it's
only in few of those many libraries this
other protein cd14 again is expressing
some of the imuno cells and is not
expressing most of the other samples but
if you look at the acting beta it is
expressed essentially everywhere now we
can um
uh um
show those graph in in in horizontal
orientation so we
show gfap and we can see it is
restricted to to to few sample but the
acting beta is expressed essentially
everywhere the median expression is zero
for the gfap but is more than Zer in
this case is around 5,000 transcript per
million in the case of fating beta
because this is EXP exess a little bit
everywhere so we can see we can
distinguish between tissue specific and
broadly expressed genes in this tissue
and then can we we can also start to ask
if the promoter of those genes are the
same or are different so we can we can
we can plot them and we can have those
gen that are that have a median of
expression that is larger than one uh
sorry more than zero so there are
housekeeping housekeeping jeans
and they are usually driven by uh cpg
promoters and then we have the other
groups that is represented here those
that have the medium of expression
around zero and which means tissue
specific and those are usually driven by
tab box promoter very often they don't
have cpg and if they don't have tab box
there are some other specific uh Motif
so we can broadly classify the type the
type of transcription by using cage most
importantly cage can provide a
transcription at a single nucleotide
resolution so we can tell exactly which
base or or all the bases that are used
in each promoter and for this we have
analyzed this promoter the the before
before gy1 promoter and in a set of
sample uh like Astros site three human
donor three biological U donors we can
see that the initiation start is very
sharp on our around a single position
here there is a t boss control in this
but if you look at a CD4 uh cd14 or
CD4 again this is all in three
biological replicas human biological
replica or if you see this this this
cell line that it was was using in the
encode we can see that initiation start
is much more changeable it just goes a
little bit a little bit everywhere but
with some reproducible pattern that are
reproducible for each set of biological
uh sample we can also uh uh group them
and we can we can group the various type
of promoters and we can automatically
call the the subcomponent of promoter
and we can also measure expression based
on each sub component of of the promoter
bringing the analysis of of of
expression at at at a different level at
a higher level that was never uh tested
before and this could not be done
possibly both by RNA sequencing or by
micro Ray because they there is no such
resolution to distinguish at a single
base with so high reproducibility so if
you really want to see where are the
initiation side on the promoter that are
using different tisue you won use the
this analysis for transcription control
cage is the perfect tool to U for this
type of analysis so to um summarize this
concept we can now distinguish each
subcomponent of promoter and their
tissue specificity some are cpg driven
some will be Tata box driven some will
have other motives and each one will
have some uh some uh tissue specificity
as represented here and this is not a
this is just a concept slide is is not
is not a real real promoter but if you
look at expression in this way and ask
how many initiation site there are in
the genome we can tell for sure there
are 180 ,000 initiation site for which
you're very sure but if you are a little
bit more aggressive you you look at
lowly expressed we we can we think that
there are up up could be even half
million of such groups that are uh kind
of treatable computationally so there is
a lot of work to do to really understand
what they are doing some of them are
driven by retrotransposon element or
other types of
elements uh this was published and there
is also a website here there's a little
bit more on on on the website later so
we can use this now to uh uh inair
regulatory Network in each cell type we
analyze because we have many many
primary cells here and that are really
very very different in and and quite
quite beautiful collection of
cells um we have the cage promoter map
and also R sequence small R sequencing
for each one of them uh the by analyzing
promoter we can see transcription Factor
binding site and then uh see if around
those transcription Factor around the
transcription the transcription Factor
Bing side of of of transcription factors
and in Fair which set of transcription
factor is responsible for the for the
expression in each of the various cell
type we can also infer uh various type
of motives that are novel and inir novel
regulatory motive for which we still
need to find some uh b side because we
have RNA S as well we can now also um um
uh go for transcript the discovery and
understand gy models a little bit better
have long non coding rnas uh that that
are being analyzing in this project not
everything was published and this is one
overview of all the the primary cells
and the tissue that we have been um um
analyzing human is so and there uh
relationship similarity and
differences it is publish in nature but
if so if you want to going to the the
test place refer to the res publication
but it's very important to I mean for
instance as a single example I can bring
is is the ccer cell line that are
represented here in the middle and quite
interesting that the ccer cell line
don't remember almost anything about
their original tissue but they cluster
together as a cancer cell line which is
quite quite interesting so and many of
many of them Cod lines are there so uh
please uh be be aware of this when when
you want to analyze the public data and
this is the portal of the website of the
Phantom we have quite a lot of visits in
the first half a month uh uh half month
and half we have about 1.4 million of
visitors and I hope that people can
still using even more the database of uh
to understand Gene uh
transcription now this is a little bit
of diverging from The Phantom but this
is another paper showing the importance
to of the high solution uh
identification of initiation site and
this is in zebra fish this the the theom
Consortium which means zra fish promoter
room we can uh uh and we have profiled a
fertili from the from the eggs to the
developing embryo and there is the
Midas transition around here where the
maternal transcript are degraded and the
zygotic transcript in bronic transcrip
are are being transcribed this is a
dramatic shift and we start to and first
of all we understood is that there are
essentially sharp promoter here Tata box
driven but there are essentially uh cpg
uh driven promoters in the in the in the
embryonic stage and also we we see that
all of this is a company by dramatic uh
rearrangement of nucleosome that are
essentially random in or not well
organized in the zygotic transcript but
they become very very well organized and
rearranged around the zygotic the
scripture having high resolution helps
to infer mechanism and the spacing and
the and the complexity of the
transcriptional Machinery the the the
RNA polymer to
now I would like to go back to the
Phantom and uh I would like to go back
to another Finding uh which related to
to identification of enhancer using uh
cage
data now uh this is this was
the second article that appear in nature
but the KE finding here was not our
funding but was a funding from various
groups uh uh identify that uh there is a
bir directional transcription in
in case of an answer so an answer are
Bal tcri as as represented here and um
uh and uh uh but the key Point here is
that uh uh we identify the tissue
specificity the cell specificity and
provide a very large uh uh cell
specificity for uh this type of of
resource um also uh we can correlate
very well cage with other specific marks
and we can provide very specific very
specific uh function for in we find uh
an answer for the for the B cells that
that is not used in CB4 and natural
killer monite and then we can extend
this analysis to all the Phantom sample
finding that there are an answer that
are specific for the various tissue and
they have all the various marked in
sensitive s
h3k4
k27
for me one and so on and all of this
makes a lot of sense in light to what we
know about the
um everything that binds the the an
answer and the key point for those
44,000 we know for about 60% of them we
know that are quite strongly sell
specific and and we can um uh really use
this for uh a lot of analysis and and
additional studies uh which is not
provide anywhere else
tissue specificity of course we we we
validate several of them and and have
have a um quite a lot of additional data
of course we we tried the first in in
cells human human cells and those have
very high validation rate in various
cells but then we also went in in in zra
fish where we have a reasonable success
for some of the neuron or neuron stem
cell um
uh uh Pro an answer the first example is
is for an answer predicted in neurons in
neural stem cell and it makes sense
because it is expressed in these areas
in the zebra fish embrio the second
example is is a is an answer that is
that is specific for for for for human
neuron tissue and we can see here on the
head on the on the this area here so
this makes a a lot of sense that the
expression is recapitulated also in zra
fish which is uh
three out of five is the the frequen
frequency that is expected to um to be
validated in in in if use a human en
answer in zra fish we can also infer
which en answer is correlated with which
promoter and this is done by analyzing
coexpression so we analyze expression or
cage tag or the and expression of cage
tax at the at the nearby promoter and
very often we infair as in the numbers
here we infer the the correlation
probably what what regulates what and
some of those lines with with with the
red line were also confirmed by by
Chet H by independent experiment
demonstrating that our our uh our
analysis can indeed reveal um
correlation and interaction between an
answerer and regulated promoters most
important Al I would say that many of
the gas that many of the the Snips that
that are associated to disease but not
associated to genes are associated to
enhancers and this is very important
because we can put many of the orphan
Jas uh back to some potential function
in enhancer region so this was quite
quite surprising and quite quite
important
aspect now uh I mention about non coding
RNA in the in the in the early part of
the the discussion but we didn't we
didn't um expand so much what they could
be possibly doing but in uh in uh in in
in in in a recent project we we start to
analyze them in in in IPS and yes we
prepare a very uh a very large
collection of cage of of on RNA
particularly nuclear RNA has been very
important in many uh replica Mouse and
human and triological replica m in human
and using nuclear not only satol and the
C was been the technology plenty of data
the key point is what we is is is our
analysis and we found a class of
transcripts called Nast which means
nonot stem
transcripts usually they are nuclear
embrionic stellular IPS
specific and those are the N so
essential
uh particularly in the nuclear are are
essentially many ingenic or anti sensori
tronic so they are is more than 70% of
the trans valadis and we can see that
they are below this orange bar which
means they are essential in the nucleus
as represented here they're also quite
specific so they are in in if you
compare with the whole Phantom they're
only in in stem cell there they are
nowhere else and they also carry uh not
only motor marks but also an answer and
answer marks so importantly we analyze
uh their their their genomic context and
surprisingly we found that many of them
are not
conserved and also here in blue there
are on retr transfusion element 40% are
on retr transfusion element and in
particular we found that many of them
are on Al element this is mouse and this
is human and uh so which was kind of
surprising most importantly then we
started to analyze their function we
start to knock down those retr transfers
element derived RNA and see if our cells
shift in in in in their in in the PO
potency by measuring the activity of
nanog after knocking down the those nood
and we can see that for for a a
reasonable number of them we can see
there is a shift and that they the cell
to
differentiate and the marker for pro
poeny nanog and then other we validated
extensively for four of those
Nas uh those are uh clearly
differentiated going down so poly
potency Market go down and the cell tend
to differentiate in in Vivo so many of
them are B directional transcript
transcript also here like in the
previous example for the Phantom so and
and they they are essentially um by
tcri suggesting that there could be an
answer we've been checking a little bit
more in details and we found both DNA Hy
sensitive
site and uh p300 suggesting that they
are uh potential an answer and because
of that we have been also uh checking
with the with Chet the
transcribed um LTR um are connecting
with active promoters while the not
transcribe are not and uh essentially if
you look at which promoter they connect
by by go by go analysis we find that
they are DNA packaging chromatin
organization or cell cycle in particular
cell cycle is very important for the
stem cell so identify rros element uh
that are an an answer and they are
connecting uh they are connecting with
with the active genes in stem cell if
you look the down the RNA the cell
differentiate suggesting that there are
some some some some
potential very interesting functionality
for this so we publish in natur genetics
quite recently and so the basic idea is
that once once upon a time there were
the ancient retroviruses that were
parasiting the the cell causing damages
but the cell has learned how to adapt
them
and and to to adopt them and uh take
advantage of them and particularly
probably because they can provide
regular element spread regulatory
element in the genome um very
efficiently and now uh those those um
for all Ral transfusion element are
producing are pro are essentially
regulating cells being acting as
promoter acting as an answer and those
are particularly important for the
existence of and maintenance of stem
cell and they are down regulated during
the differentiation of stem cell and
it's not only us also Professor yamanaka
aty university has recently found some
of the some of those LTR element that
are
also also regulated and down regulated
during the differentiation of of cells
we have a little bit more stories about
what was used to be called
Junk and still many people consider junk
but we we are looking at this quite
quite uh quite carefully uh one is that
we found uh many of those altr element
slightly different classes but but again
those altr element that are uh very
highly expressed in in in cancer and
particularly they are uh particular in
liver cancer and in in tumors and
they're not not expressed in normal
tumors or in other types of cell as as
represented here so um the final story I
would like to tell about about this is
that is that
uh the final uh class of no coding Aron
that we've been analyzing and here we
were interested in sense anti sense so
particularly the sense is represented
here by this green RNA and the anti
sense is this red RNA in the opposite
orientation and this is a gene U L1 that
is important for the for the familiar
Parkinson's disease we overexpress drna
in cells and we saw that if you overe
express the RNA the sense RNA doesn't
change at all in expression level
however if you look at the protein level
we see that the protein level is
dramatically enhanced is not inhibited
is enhanced in the cont what everybody
expected so so those nood help the cell
to make specifically much more protein
we've been looking at what what are the
the responsible sequence and we found
that by computer an analysis we find
that there some sign B2 element here
represented in this green part if we
delete this sequence here we see that we
cannot we cannot have anymore the uh
induction of protein translation in in
in in in in in in our cells so we try to
see if you can transfer this property to
uh to additional rnas by changing the
anti sense region so we we we design
those rnas that we call now sign up we
call the sign element up regulating
translation so if you change the anti-
sense region we change the specificity
and we see that we can also uh and uh
bring this to the gfp so we can produce
more gfp if you change the anti sense
region and use the the remaining part of
the sb2
element uh this was again publish uh
some sometimes ago but the basic idea is
that we can have a a tool that is a just
the opposite of Si or micro RNA and by
changing the overlapping region with the
Val and messenger R we can now change
the specificity and uh and uh do various
application now in the lab we are very
intensively working to
to explore all of these application
optimize sense sense region and we can
use this in vitro inv Vivo in cells and
there is a quite big uh things ahead so
um I like to conclude uh saying of
course there's plenty of work ahead uh
there is plenty of uh unknown stuff here
in the you know in this unexplored part
of the of the transp is very exciting
and uh what what we better need the
functional sa and we need also young
scientists uh also to to to come and
work with us or work
independently um but anyway we needed
those those tools and in general because
all of this was about funding a function
of out of the junk out of the
noncoding um I think there better to uh
be very open we don't claim that they
have function but uh very uh very often
there may be function and
as very important people said that uh we
should be very careful and try to see
what the facts are telling are telling
us rather than sticking on the on on the
basic idea i' like to uh show a little
bit bit of the the Phantom Consortium I
like to thank many people uh for for
this activity and you know clearly I
cannot read all of them but they they
will stay online and uh if you scroll
for you can read all the name or uh look
at them in the in the acknowledgement of
the Phantom paper is also the en code
Consortium and additional grants and uh
we are in yohama if you have some
interest please don't hesitate to
contact to contact me and U yeah this is
a list of of Grant and I'm open for
question and uh I think that there is a
question and U
uh uh some question online I guess I
must read the question and uh
uh is the uh dear is atoshi
uh uh dinga I apologize if I don't
if Asos dinga and uh uh the question is
De greting from tuing and Germany my
question is in is
U is Rel to J targeting free focus on on
making knockout in IPS especially using
Talent Cris per cast n can targeting TSS
site instead of random sit in the G for
noout would work better and also
possible to reduce of Target effect this
is clearly a very good point I uh well
uh we we didn't do it yet but I I I
believe that targeting initiation site
is probably uh going to be very
effective uh I think that the key point
is to identify which part of the
promoter is is is is important if you
have a very accurate initiation site
driven by tatab box clearly you can
Target that very very well and uh and
and and you you can eliminate that part
very carefully uh however uh if the
sequence is very long like if you have a
Long cpg Island and you have a
initiation site over 50 or 100 or 200
base pairs my you you may have to delete
the whole regions I think and so I think
that you need to really um be quite
careful on which part is um is is is is
eliminated uh we often see that if you
eliminate some some component of
promoter some other part of the G may
take over and and create a new
initiation side so I think is is a
little bit a little bit
complex and uh at the moment I don't I
don't see um I don't have other
questions so um still be available here
for for a couple of for a minute or two
if anyone would like to would like to
okay there is a uh another question is
from ah Mario uh who is a uh yeah
actually he's he's he's Marian um banin
is actually is our student here um uh
see you have a long history develop uh
uh uh I see you have a long history of
development of new tag sequencing
protocols any plans for new ones cage
successor maybe uh for upcoming phantom
phantom six or Phantom
project okay uh this is uh uh clearly we
are um developing new new tools all all
the time and and um in in in the current
development of Technology we have been
working intensively to to optimize to
standardize in order to
have very reproducible U uh uh result
over no over time this has been one one
of the very is it's not so exciting but
is very important standardization is
very important the other one is to go on
the single cell and and uh on a single
cell capturing as many RNA as possible
or IDE most of the rnas uh going on on
the single cell and this is what we are
working on with with several colleagues
including sharp see and this group here
at
Ren right um and
uh all right so um let me see oh okay
there is no uh no questions available
anymore so I would like to uh thank
everybody for uh uh for the attention
for the possibility to be here I hope I
hope the video will be uh Avail will be
online and uh please don't hesitate to
contact me whatever other question you
have visit us visit visit the website
write to me and thank you very much
again to everybody
bye-bye